tout le monde peut s'y mettre cinéma
johnny hallyday face à jean rochefort un
braqueur face à un prof à la retraite
c'est la fiche du dernier film de
patrice leconte l'homme du train
sortie demain on dit que c'est le
meilleur rôle de johnny au cinéma
marie-jo jouant bernard puissesseau l'un
rêve d'être un aventurier moyenne proche
de pointe ou l'autre de se ranger enfin
pourquoi but est vraiment plus là et
prof à la retraite plus tôt à lui mais
l'autre d'auxerre plutôt fatigué bref
voilà de nature que tout oppose et qui
voudrais bien échanger leurs autres les
scénarios du sur mesure ce qui prime ici
c'est la rencontre et ça c'est alain
spécificité ne veulent pas il suffit de
voir ce film de voir les regards qu'ils
me lance avec ses beaux yeux bleus ont
tout hétérosexualité avec ses beaux yeux
bleus
il ya une espèce de progression vers la
tendresse quoi des amitiés d'hommes mais
nous là on est deux on forme une éthique
la coupe d'une pruche très sérieuse ou
hilal quelque chose de très grave a dit
on entend dire hélas pas le faire j'ai
fait wow wow
et pourtant il était intimidé johnny
devant un tel partenaire de leur
rencontre est née une belle complicité
dans la vie à 72 ans jean rochefort peut
même se comporter en mi mineur
alors je dis à ses fans vous avez raison
d'aimer ce garçon parce que il est aussi
fort en tant que chanteur canton comme
un homme extrêmement intéressant
authentique toujours lui même
falletti avant preuve en 30 ans
d'enseignement pas ça la touche mans
sexuelle à me reprocher chapeau patrice
leconte a misé juste jean rochefort
johnny hallyday voilà un duo qui
fonctionne à merveille
il fallait y penser fin de cette édition
merci de l'avoir